what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I am back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest development
in the demon slayer story in this
chapter we got some of the biggest
reveals yet so definitely stay tuned for
that if you enjoyed these Demon Slayer
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future demon sailor chapter reviews
a quick thank you goes out to our
glorious patrons who helped make videos
like this one possible more on you
amazing people later for now keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers in
this video we are discussing the latest
chapter chapter 196 after all now
without further ado let's jump into it
if you remember last chapter was crazy
we had a guru and tundra door kicking
butt and moves on being driven to a
corner also nez ago finally returned and
one of her eyes was human suggesting
that the medicine was working and that
she was in the process of transitioning
back from demon to human this chapter
starts with Mexico and it's called I am
remember that as usual it will be
relevant later we see Medical from a
distance walking in the cover page she's
sweating and panting she starts seeing
some memories from when her family was
still alive we see nestled close and
Tundras cute little siblings and their
mother smiling and laughing we see that
the zoo close left eye is still doubt of
a demon and to match the eye the left
side of her mouth still has those
vampire like canine teeth while the
right side is normal again
interestingly enough she is crying from
her right eye a gave her human eye she
is not crying from her demon eye though
so there is still struggle within her
the human is coming back and she's
regaining her memories but the demon is
in there too seemingly at war with the
human the question is which one will win
out the idyllic memories of her family
being happy is starkly contrasted to the
nightmarish memory of Musa and what he
did to her and her family in her
memories her young sibling is warning
her to run Mouzon is using his tentacle
powers to butcher the family in contrast
to how we've been seeing him for the
last few chapters Mulan is completely
calm cool and collected here he is
clearly comfortable
and confident in his power he's
seemingly talking to himself he's using
now circles family as test subjects and
he's noticing that they die when
injected with a certain amount of blood
he reaffirms that he cannot easily
create a demon who can conquer the Sun
Meza Co remembering this is now angry
her tears have stopped and her veins are
bulging she then starts to see things
that happen since Mouzon turned her into
a demon and she lost her memories she
remembers a crying tangelo a stoic view
a waving secondi a smiling Tamayo
a teasing you shoot oh and infatuated
xited - with flowers and a manly in the
sky sharing nuts she's overwhelmed by
this influx of memories and she falls to
the ground
she continues to remember she remembers
the kind kagayaku by Isshiki the mean
son of me who hurt her and tried to
tempt her the nice girls from the
Butterfly estate including Shinobu who
even though no school was a demon asked
her if she wanted to see her goldfish
since we know how much Nobu hated demons
this is really touching we also see my
boy
giorgia role playing Goku looking back
at her no matter what happens that dude
seems to smile bravely in the face of it
all even in the face of that I really
like these shots from des écoles
perspective that's something demon sir
does well we'll often revisit moments
again like your deities fight against
moves on for instance but will be shown
different perspectives one perspective
can be limiting well we start to get a
better sense of the moment when we start
to see them from more perspectives
that's one of the messages of this manga
it wants us to see the complexity of
experiences by sharing multiple
perspectives
in doing so it foregrounds the point
that we shouldn't be quick to judge
others rather we should try to
understand where they're coming from
some people judged our precious nesco to
be a monster at first because she was a
demon but clearly Nestle remembers
everything that happened when she was a
demon she remembers the pain that sana
me caused her but also the moments of
companionship that zenit we know station
oh boo and the rest offered to her she
remembers the smiles from the sound
pillar tank and ooze we and his wives
the hand waves of the sword smiths
a smile from ganya a smile from the mist
pillar
Moochie roto kitto these little moments
which may not seem like such a big deal
seem to add up and help her to complete
her transition
back into a human from a demon her hand
turns back into a human hand without the
demon like claws she sees times offering
her hand to her and then his smiling
loving face he stood by her throughout
this whole experience and she knows that
mezu Cole's struggling the demon side
seems to be fighting for control
however she remembers Tantra taking her
hand he says and I quote no matter what
happens your big brother is going to
save you and quote she looks at the moon
we jump to a panel of her face she's
crying with both eyes now they're human
again and she's free of vampire teeth
the transition is complete and she's
human again her memories are all back
and she says to herself and I quote I am
Nessa krocomodo a demon killed my family
and quote thus Tantra has done it he has
saved her and it wasn't just his
physical protection which saved her
although he did save her many times when
demon Slayers wanted to kill her it was
also his love and kindness that helped
her turn back to human this is a
beautiful moment and it's nice to see
the power of friendship love and
kindness being foregrounded rather than
just the power of swords or other
weapons this moment doesn't come off as
corny at all to me and it gives me a
newfound appreciation for just how much
time did for nesic oh it's also nice
seeing how all of the little moments of
kindness from the others helped Naza KO
a smile here a wave there it goes to
show that you can really help someone
out sometimes by giving them a smile a
friendly wave or just being kind to them
in real life being a good person is more
often about caring for someone rather
than about kicking the bad guys but even
Sarah manages to show that in a
beautiful way within a shown infighting
manga and that's pretty special however
never fear the mangaka is not going to
leave out the fighting either next we
see the moon from the perspective of the
battlefield moves on and times are going
at it tentacle moonwalk vs. dance of the
fire god ton sure reminds himself to
stand firm he reminds himself not to get
too ahead in the future he just needs to
by one second and then another that's
the only way to tackle a seemingly
impossible task just focus on doing what
you have to do during this present
moment otherwise he'll get overwhelmed
lose your cool and mess
moves on for his part senses life he
senses that the pillars he injured and
probably sided 20 no ski are coming to
his attacks were enough to injure them
pretty badly and they should have even
been fatal but the demon Slayers are not
dead because tomorrow's demon aku Shiro
is treating them again Tommy Oh through
you should at this time continues to be
an ever-present thorn and moves on side
even from beyond the grave Musleh at
first thinks that it's tangibles fault
that he couldn't finish the pillars off
but then he realizes it's not just her
protagonist the members of the demon
slayer core are linked like beads in a
rosary he compares the organization to a
living creature seeking to capture him
the Demon Slayer core is represented as
a dragon which is noteworthy because we
know both zani twos and tangelos moves
have taken the forms of dragons also
dragons are arguably the strongest
creature you can think of for instance
keidel said to be the strongest creature
in one piece can turn into a dragon
dragons ROP and that shows that Mulan is
feeling overpowered and perhaps a little
powerless when faced with the
organization as a whole
he is the prey being hunted by the
organization no matter who he kills and
who dies someone comes to replace them
and builds on their hard work in this
way the organization keeps inexhaustibly
coming after moves on the crow then says
that there are 35 minutes until dawn
apparently giving moves on an update as
well as our guys I'd laugh if the crow
was lying this whole time and there were
actually only like five minutes left but
it was trying to throw off moves on that
would be pretty hilarious even with 35
minutes left though moves on feels like
he needs to get out ASAP in his view he
can't risk it any longer time Joe
notices that Mulan is planning something
and he recalls what Mulan did during his
fight against yuuichi to escape tundra
wasn't sure how he'd stop him from
escaping but he fought anyway now Mulan
is trying to do it he's trying to
explode into a bunch of small pieces of
flesh so that he can escape and regroup
tundra thinks about whether he and ego
could stop him but he determines that he
wouldn't be able to stop moves on if he
divides tundra thinks his only hope is
striking twelve spots all at once
just as tundra is at his most desperate
Mulan's arm that was about to
flowdde goes back to normal the
explosion didn't happen and both tundra
and Mulan are shocked and guess who's to
thank freakin cameo again as Mulan
points out along with human regression
and aging she added division prevention
to the drug then as if that wasn't
enough
Tomeo says she added something else two
moves on search coughing up blood
and Tommy oh who sells our inside moves
on says she's added a fourth substance
after the other three weakened him the
fourth will begin cell destruction
she tells Milan that his most hated
thing death is now so close and that
ends this glorious chapter Wow Tommy oh
never ceases to amaze me last chapter I
mentioned that she may have some tricks
left up her sleeves but I didn't expect
this much she definitely over delivered
and the more the story goes on the more
clear it is that you're eating made the
right decision in sparing her and that
the demon stairs of your Ricci's time
were wrong to condemn him for saving a
demon second chances can definitely pay
off your Ichi and Tommy have by far done
the most to set the stage for this
battle and make victory possible it took
Demon Slayer working together with demon
to get this far it's not a coincidence
that a demon that moves on created is
responsible for his approaching downfall
the mangaka in other words is saying
that moves on did this to himself his
downfall is of his own making because of
the horrible things he did all in the
hopes of avoiding death it's karma moves
on treated others cruelly so it makes
sense that they do what they can to get
back at him and even use the demon
powers he gave them to help them do it I
also love the fact that Tundra kept
fighting even when he had no idea how
he'd stopped the flesh explosion a
lesser man would have thought it was
pointless to try to kill Mouzon since he
could just escape but Tundra just kept
fighting doing the best that he could in
the moment it ended up paying off
because Tama you ended up taking care of
moves on secret escape plan it goes to
show that you shouldn't give up in an
endeavor just because you're not sure at
this moment exactly how it will work out
but anyways this looks extremely bad for
moves on right now he's weaker than ever
he can't use his flesh explosion escape
trick he's coughing up
Kandra and eager are still there the
others are regaining consciousness
thanks to you shiro mezack was fully
human by the looks of it
so moves on seemingly can't absorb her
to become immune to the sun anymore the
cards cannot be stacked more heavily
against moves on right now this could
really be the end since we know that the
mangaka is cool with letting villains be
defeated before they go full power
obviously there is also a chance that
moves on has another trick up his
sleeves but then again he doesn't have
any sleeves right now and things seem to
really be wrapping up that Zuko has
regained her memories and is humid again
tundra saved her and that was his goal
from the beginning moves on seemingly
can't become immune to the Sun and he
can't escape uri cheese and tomatoes
plans have come into fruition we even
got a kind of recap rune ESCOs memories
this chapter of all the times we've been
through since the beginning of the
series and the people who sacrificed
their lives so that we could get to this
point for all these reasons I really
wouldn't be surprised if this turns out
to be the end of moves on and the end of
the series but let me know what you
think do you think moves on has a secret
weapon or technique that he still hasn't
used and that even your DG doesn't know
about the only problem with that theory
seems to be that moves on really appears
to be worried and freaking out so his
only chance might be to unlock a new
form and/or power that he didn't even
know he was capable of but that's it for
this chapter review thank you so much
for listening if you do enjoy these
trapped reviews I want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future chapter reviews and you
don't want that since as we can see
things are getting crazy right about now
a special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans steven grata alo long autumn the
world stealers the school bus tyson
Corino a quiet respect and pat a heffa
and i can't forget our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole Cassatt
Suki alpha do angel
team Sparky sixty-five cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc Joel Stanton
JCCC waka very Gucci and Jessica kala
fond thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon comm anime out
drawer and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer which ever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]